Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
Đỗ Bảo Nam vào lúc video ngày hôm nay Đỗ
Bảo Nam Block sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách di
chuyển hình ảnh trong Word
và trong video này đâu bà Nam blog sẽ
chia sẻ với bạn 3 cách di chuyển ảnh ảnh
và cách duy nhất bạn có thể dùng tính
năng cắt dán văn bản
đá quý ở dưới đây đâu Bà nằm ở Đông đã
có một đoạn văn bản và được chèn sẵn
hình ảnh
để di chuyển hình ảnh theo cách này thì
đầu tiên bạn chỉ cần kích chuột vào hình
ảnh
sau đó bạn có thể nhấn tổ hợp phím can x
để cắt hình ảnh
tiếp theo bạn đưa dấu nháy chuột vào
đúng với Trí mà bạn muốn chuyển ảnh đến
với độ mình muốn chuyển anh đến vị trí
này thì mình chỉ cần đưa giống ai thuật
vào đúng vị trí Cần chèn
và bạn nhấn tổ hợp phím Control V để dán
hình ảnh
Ừ như vậy là mình đã di truyền hình ảnh
Song
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang cách like đó là
dùng tính năng huatec đây là một tính
năng rất hay
và các bước bạn thực hiện như sau
đầu tiên bạn kích vào hình ảnh để chọn
ảnh
sau đó bạn vào menu Smash ít
A và kết và huatec à anh ta đi bạn có
rất nhiều kiểu hoa tích ví dụ mình sẽ
chọn kiểu Square
và sau đó bạn chỉ cần nhứt và giữ chuột
trái vào ảnh và di chuyển đến một vị trí
bất kì mà bạn muốn Ví dụ mình sẽ di
chuyển lên vị trí trên này
sau khi bạn đã di chuyển đến đúng vị trí
Cần chèn thì bạn chỉ cần nhà thôi trái
và đây là một trong những cách di chuyển
ảnh rất hiệu quả
Bạn có thể áp dụng trong rất nhiều
trường hợp
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang Cách thứ ba đó là
kéo dài hình ảnh
trên thực tế cách ba này đã được mình sử
dụng ở trong cái cách dai này bạn chỉ
cần click và giữ chuột trái vào hình ảnh
sau đó bạn di chuyển ảnh đến một vị trí
bất kì mà bạn muốn
ở trong một số trường hợp nếu như vẫn
chưa cho Aptech thì khi bạn kéo thả hình
ảnh vị trí có ảnh có thể không được như
ý muốn do vậy bạn có thể chọn mất tích
trước khi kéo dài hình ảnh
và như vậy Ở nội dung video rồi đâu bạn
em lúc đã chia sẻ với bạn một số cách để
di chuyển ảnh trong Word Cảm ơn bạn đã
theo dõi video Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại
bạn ở các video tiếp theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn hay nhất truyện phần 2 và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam với hợp
đồng thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ
bà Nam một lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào
nút đăng ký và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video cũng từ đỗ vào nam và lúc Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam với ạ A
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam plus.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blog để xem
thêm các video hữu ích như thủ thuật máy
tính tay pro sơ
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bà Nam một nước chấm
com để cập nhật những bài viết thôi mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo